was mache ich hier eigentlich und wo ist
meine weiße wand
[Musik]
ihr habt uns sehr viele schöne schlaue
fragen gestellt und wir kommen nicht
hinterher
sie alle in videos zu beantworten
deswegen willkommen zum ersten community
mix oder community speed dating erinnert
euch an das deo anders der hand das
video erinnert euch an das video über
die aluminium salz im deo sind sie
schädlich oder nicht julius mai wo
möchte wissen wie ist das mit den fluren
in der zahnpasta sind die schädlich
fluoride gehören zu den wichtigsten
bestandteil einer zahnpasta weil sie
karies vorbeugen und den zahnschmelz
aufbauen auf florid freie zahnpasta kann
man zurückgreifen wenn man lieber karies
haben möchte allerdings sollen vor allem
kinder zahnpasta nicht essen
beziehungsweise generell bitte keine
zahnpasta essen zu viel floride sind in
der tat schädlich zähneputzen da sind
sich die wissenschaftler allerdings
einig ist safe muskel machen möchte
wissen wie das mit den silikonen im
shampoo ist silikone verleihen trockenem
haar glanz und sind gesundheitlich
unbedenklich allerdings lassen sie sich
nicht richtig auswaschen bleiben auf dem
haar zurück und beschweren es so ich
habe zum beispiel recht dicke und
ziemlich trockene haare und hab ich
nicht gegen silikone eben weil sie mein
haar beschweren wenn ihr aber lieber
freie haare haben möchte dann ist ein
silikon frei shampoo für euch das
richtige rennt über möchte den
unterschied zwischen tein und koffein
wissen die ihn und koffein sind erstmals
zwei verschiedene namen für ein und
dieselbe chemische substanz nämlich
koffein nur nennen wir sie in t manchmal
aus einem grund tein kaffee enthält mehr
koffein als tigers koffein mit dem
gehirn macht das haben wir hier schon
geklärt dafür enthält mehr
antioxidantien wie zum beispiel
flavonoide die gut für unser herz
kreislaufsystems es gibt verschiedene
studien die nicht nur tee sondern auch
kaffee positive gesundheitliche effekte
zu schreiben allerdings sind die relativ
klein im verhältnis zu anderen lifestyle
choices bewegung sport oder der verzicht
auf rauchen und alkohol fallen da
deutlich stärker ins gewicht und kehrt
ganz so laut und herzen möchte wissen
warum schauen bei cooler sofort
verschwindet bei ihr aber nicht denn
schaum stabiles dann sind sogenannte
grenzflächen aktive substanzen vorhanden
brenzlichen aktive substanzen wie zum
beispiel tenside in seiffen lagern
sicher gewaltig und lagern sich
bevorzugt an grenzflächen an zum
beispiel an wasser luft grenzflächen und
stabilisieren so den schaum bei den
meisten getreten verschwindet der schon
ein paar sekunden
hier hat agierte in sich und bringt das
grenzflächen aktive protein ltp 190 dass
sie schaum so stabil macht michael
scheitern möchte wissen was der
unterschied zwischen zucker und zucker
ersatzstoffen ist das ist eine sehr gute
frage so gut dass wir sie nächste woche
in einem ganzen video beantworten
deswegen nächsten donnerstag an die
zuschauer
ok h interessant hier steht appellieren
was das bedeutet das erinnert mich
irgendwie ein bisschen das was ich immer
am ende vom video sage